thank you thank you very much
Dance Moms star Abby Lee Miller appeared
in a Pittsburgh courtroom Monday and
pleaded guilty to bankruptcy fraud and
money laundering today miss Miller
accepted responsibility accepted
responsibility by pleading guilty to one
count of concealing assets of her
bankruptcy estate and one common volva
currency reporting requirements related
to international travel mr. Dahmer filed
for bankruptcy protection in 2010 her
creditors incurred no loss sentencing in
this case will occur after the United
States Court of Appeals for the Third
Circuit resolves United States versus
freed a similar case addressing the
issue of sentencing in a zero loss
bankruptcy the court will resolve all
outstanding matters Miller was first
accused last October of illegally trying
to hide seven hundred and seventy five
thousand dollars worth of income from
Dance Moms and of the lifetime show's
spin-off projects when she filed for
chapter 11 bankruptcy at the time she
pleaded not guilty last week federal
prosecutors added a currency reporting
charge stemming from her return to the
States from Australia in August 2014
throughout this case miss Miller has
taken both the allegations and the
proceedings very seriously this has been
a challenging time for Miss Miller she
appreciates the words of encouragement
and support from around the